c'est de ce village que la compagnie du
sergent unistrate a progressé au
lancement de la contre-offensive nous
roulons à travers les anciennes
positions russes vous voyez c'était les
premières positions russes c'était de la
forêt et là où il n'y a plus de forêt
c'est leur position qu'on a attaquée
les hommes de la 68e brigade ont repris
bla aux dates né en 18 heures mais
depuis les Russes situées à 900 mètres
Arsène les forces ukrainiennes
il n'y a plus du tout de russe mais en
permanence quelque chose nous arrive
dessus de l'artillerie des attaques de
Rocket grade ici on peut avoir toute la
collection d'attaques possible sur les
positions
ils attaquent toutes les heures
les seuls soldats russes qui restent
dans le village sont morts ici et de
plus là-bas
les hommes du sergent aulnistrate
affirment toutefois que l'ennemi s'est
adapté tant sur terre que dans les airs
en ce moment ils emploient des nouvelles
tactiques maintenant les avions et les
hélicoptères ne s'aventurent pas au-delà
de la zone grise il tire et font
immédiatement demi-tour
il venait au-dessus de nos têtes
pour les opérateurs de drone d'attaque
la tâche est aussi plus ardue ils se
sont vraiment améliorés dans la guerre
électronique les contre-mesures pour les
drones et ils ont plus de brouilleurs il
y a 6 mois on ne voyait pas si souvent
des fusils anti-drone et maintenant il y
en a dans chaque tranchée c'est donc
plus dangereux et plus difficile pour
nous de voler
un soldat de la brigade rentre de 7
jours passés au front il témoigne d'une
progression lente et d'une forte
résistance russe
on prend des positions on se bat quand
ils veulent les reprendre et ça se fait
petit à petit pas à pas que vous soyez
meilleur ou pas il y aura toujours des
pertes
si les soldats sur les positions sont
déterminés le sergent au nistrat est
préoccupé par le peu d'enthousiasme du
reste de la société lorsqu'il s'agit
d'aller se battre
les gens sont fatigués de la guerre la
plupart des gens ont décidé de même que
la guerre était finie
j'ai bien vu à Kiev Kiev c'est une
atmosphère tellement différente
lui connaît le prix de l'engagement deux
jours avant la contre-offensive son fils
de 21 ans a été tué par une frappe de
drone
c'était mon idée
on en a beaucoup parlé
et puis il m'a dit que c'était une
décision qui venait des tripes
et il y a les
je pensais que j'aurais pu le protéger
mais il voulait être un héros à mes yeux
et c'est tout c'est tout
il a gagné
ce père endeuillé c'est qu'il doit aussi
rester un commandant concentré les mois
à venir seront difficiles
à proximité des roquettes de longue
portée sont tirées car les arrières de
l'ennemi
[Musique]